i had my mind blown one day as an
undergrad at the physics computer lab i
logged in and you know when you log into
bash for a long time there was a little
fortune that would come out and it said
man was created by water to carry itself
uphill
and i was logging in to work on some you
know problem set
and i logged in and i saw that and i
just said son of a [ __ ] you know i just
i logged out i went to the coffee shop
and i got a coffee and i sat there on
the quad like
you know
it's not wrong and yet wtf right
um so when you look at it that way it's
like yeah okay non-equilibrium physics
is a thing
and so when we think about love when we
think about these kinds of things
i would say that in the modern day human
condition
there's a lot of talk about freedom and
individual liberty and rights and all
these things
but that's a that's very hegelian it's
very kind of following from the western
philosophy
of of the the individual as a sacrosanct
but
it's not really couched i think the the
right way because it should be how do we
maximize people's ability to love each
other to love themselves first to love
each other their responsibilities to the
previous generation to the future
generations
those are the kinds of things that
should be our design criteria right
those should be
what we start with
to then come up with the philosophies of
self and of rights and responsibilities
but that love being at the center of it
i think when we design systems for
cognition
it should absolutely be built that way i
think if we simply focus on efficiency
and productivity these kind of very uh
industrial era
um you know all the things that marx had
issues with right those that's that's a
way to go and and really i think go off
the deep end in the wrong way
you